lighting 15% increases
fluorine 10 to 25% if the tariffs go for
this glass doors going up 10%
George Abbie huh beeps remodeling
business in San Diego is bracing for the
new abnormal 25% tariffs being imposed
by the US on two hundred billion dollars
in Chinese goods of from ten percent
last year many materials used in home
building and remodeling gar included
you've got a lot of things like granite
that's are gonna be sourced from China
small business owners like IB Aviv are
worried that potential clients due to
the tariffs on Chinese goods will balk
at soon-to-come higher price quotes it
takes a long time for customers to
digest the new reality of what things
cost and in the meantime we have a very
large overhead and about 50 staff that
we need to ensure have continual work
his concerns are twofold that many
homeowners will put off major
improvements like getting a new kitchen
and that to attract potential clients
he'll need to reduce his profit margin
you're in a position where you could be
losing 20 or 30 percent of your net
profits at the end of the year you're
eating some of the cost in other words
definitely if we can't pass on all of it
to the customer we end up eating it
ourselves the alternatives for these are
much much more expensive when they're
made in the States
obviousiy says his clients prefer
higher-end products manufactured in
America the supplier says but even from
these suppliers he's receiving ominous
emails they thank us for our business
and they say that our industry is under
unprecedented pressure due to tariffs
and we've waited as long as we can for
possible price increases do these
tariffs so this is an American cabinet
line but this is built on engineered
wood part of the Chinese supply chain to
give us a better idea of what the new
China tariffs will mean for customers
wvv takes us to a worksite this is the
$75,000 kitchen
so as you can see this is a complete gut
job
ah bo-beep says because of the new
increased tariffs you'll need to charge
for a renovation like this one
six thousand dollars more than he did a
year ago $6,000 on a $75,000 kitchen is
a very big increase is it a deal breaker
it is definitely a deal breaker one of
the impacts of the tariff is not simply
the price increase but also the delay in
investment and the delay in investment
will come from consumers for example
delaying a home remodel Renee Balan a
professor of international trade policy
at the University of California San
Diego says the tariffs could be damaging
to the US economy it's a big deal it's
going to affect US consumers a lot
you've been studying tariffs and trade
for decades now right correct have you
seen anything quite like this never seen
anything like this I've been having to
rewrite my classes essentially the
United States would like to think that
China will be more hurt by the US
tariffs than the US will be hurt by the
Chinese tariffs but that's to be
determined the Trump administration is
also taking steps to impose fresh 25%
tariffs on nearly 300 billion dollars in
Chinese goods that aren't currently
taxed I think this is a risk we should
and can take without damaging our
economy in any appreciable way the Trump
administration hopes that ultimately a
deal with China will be reached that
benefits US producers there may be more
made in America as a result of the
tariffs consumers now are forced to
purchase from domestic producers who
have higher prices naturally while
producers are enjoying this welfare game
consumers are losing this tile and
flooring store in San Diego primarily
serves customers who've got tighter
budgets this is our wood looking luxury
vinyl plank which is one of the most
popular items nowadays and where's it
from this product is actually a Chinese
product even with the tariff increases
on these products on anything out of
China they're still going to be less
expensive than an american-made product
even with a 20
that's correct the trade war is bad news
for everyone but particularly the middle
class and lower income Americans
lower-income Americans lower-income
Americans benefit from the very cheap
products that are coming from China so
let's head down over to the warehouse
verónica tariqas says about 90% of the
products for company sales come from
China so now if you take a look here you
will see made in China
here made in China tarika says she's
nervous I Azzam as a manager have to
worry about for instance my staff's jobs
our company when the first round of
tariffs on Chinese goods hit last fall
she says sales dropped off pretty much
immediately we're talking about 33% so
1/3 less sales exactly right when you're
confident that it's because of the
tariffs yes it was just very very busy
and it came to a screeching halt as soon
as the tariff says doing this the tariff
set and the new increased round is
expected to hit soon goods that are
already in transit will not be subject
to the terrace
but goods being loaded on ships in China
now will have to pay the tariff when
they arrive so we will see a small delay
in the impact of these tariffs about two
weeks but the tariffs are literally on
their way
correct the tariffs are literally on
their way